[Musique]
c'est tout de suite à la minute garrido
mais juste avant il ya la deuxième
partie de la caméra cachée de greg
guillotin c'est le coup de coeur de mon
jean luc parce que c'est vrai qu'on
n'aime pas me la semaine dernière et ce
sera la dernière et demain vous verrez
il a fait un truc là sur un escalator on
va repasser et à partir de la semaine
prochaine à ce seront ils en train de
tourner des trucs dans la rue fougue
guillotin je sais que vous l'adorez il
ya des gens qui le réclame jean luc
c'est votre coup de coeur
je suis content parce que j'ai été piégé
par eric guillotin aussi et j'ai vu la
première partie de votre première de
votre caméra cachée et j'ai hâte de voir
la suite
et franchement c'est ça fait du bien de
vous faire avoir il est énorme c'est
vrai qu'il m'a baisé s'engage rôle tarn
ont beaucoup ce que vous faites ici
aussi tout merci ainsi qu'on a un peu en
mode de fusée en ce moment et si on veut
mais là tu vois avec des gens qui
évoluent il ya un côté un peu bruyant tu
rigole tout le temps pour rien puisqu'il
fait toi confiance quoi t'es bon quoi tu
as du talent je veux pas que moi je
ramène un truc un peu plus français
cyril hanouna piéger par le youtuber
tête à claques deuxième partie le
problème numéro un c'est qu'on cohanim
ensemble donc l'affairé
en fait c'est que du coup ça se cherche
un piégeage après tu veux mettre
vraiment je déconne je suis là tous les
jours justement mais je ne connais même
pas je veux toujours ont fait qu anime
ensemble moi avec ma tête de breton toi
ta tête de juif on se passe des vallées
tout le temps ensuite au niveau des
chroniqueurs ça en fera du ménage de
leur mort déjà voilà donc je donnerais
tu me prends pas au sérieux mais je te
jure
les cheveux quand sa corde oui bernardet
se dégage ça saute ça se voit même là ça
fonctionne je trouve quand on interagit
ça toi tu m'écoutes je trouve que tu as
de l' écoute et moi je et moi j'ai de la
propre à la temps je termine juste vite
fait parce que je sais que t'as pas
beaucoup de temps et non dans 15 minutes
faut qu'on soit parti non mais moi et
moi dans mon coeur et je suis partie des
ateliers
la proposition que j'avais faite en fait
à deux marques qui sont forts qu'ils
sont c'est pour nous ces cadeaux et la
grande brasserie est en fait tu me tues
ferait plus pressé pour nous sert à sera
je mixe les deux jeudi à une famille on
va vous offrir une belle maison parce
que je trouvais ça super dense et pas un
mot c'est cadeau donc les gens viennent
y voit la maison ils sont contents la
famille et la ville pense est donc forcé
pour nous c'est cadeau du super nickel
c'était en fait ils sont dans la grâce à
une caméra cachée il ya un bulldozer qui
défonce la maison c'est qu'il adore mon
corps mais après on rentre leurs données
compensation tu vois des trucs ou une
place de cinéma ça mais bon bah voilà
écoutez on
on y va du lean avons entamé les jeunes
adhèrent pas bah pas en ajouter ok bon
ben ça durant pour le pognon et tous de
lourdes au moment où je suis désolé mais
si on sait encore tu as fait tu passes
en coûte rien
bon c'est des caméras cachées
j'adorais armée comme ça autour château
va voir que des nouveautés maintenant je
vous le dis c'est énorme ce qu'ils nous
préparent guillotin et david qu'on
embrasse fort aussi un sont associés les
chiffres